[Music]
oh my god yes sorry I'm saying that yeah
that's adorable
oh my god that's so cute hey what yeah
I'll poop here how do you know him I
don't know we have to figure that out
okay let's catch him out of place you
hate butterflies right don't worry God
why am you caught a ladybug
do I like ladybugs yay no no okay again
finally you're doing something useful
for the thing okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I
am I am bad boyfriend I'm sorry your
shitty girlfriend no I just stopped
showing your nibs please okay thank you
what are you doing what are you doing
right now
I what are you doing oh my god you did
so well my dad thank you so much for
playing with me today
[Music]
for the thumbnail we do a little kiss
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know y'all can't handle this [ __ ]
I know y'all gonna flag this [ __ ]
video like you always do and I have to
call Google and be like hey they flagged
another one yeah my ad my fan base is
basically a bunch of [ __ ] oh this
video had blood in it
oh this video had nipples in it boo this
video was a little bit too sexual
ooh he may be swirl excuse me why don't
you just go to the [ __ ] Australia
like the good old days what do you bet
you even flag this video already because
you're triggered by my glasses you're
all a bunch of wimps don't like [ __ ]
video all right
stop flying the video I'm sick and tired
of this [ __ ] shake can y'all stop
flagging my [ __ ] videos stop flagging
the videos god damn it I don't make any
money if you flag the video what do you
think I'd do this for free do you think
I'm some kind of [ __ ] charity do you
think I do this for fun do you think I
do YouTube for fun are you only knit for
the money
[ __ ] you we're even thinking that all
right now I gotta make this video and
it'd be great if you don't [ __ ] flag
it alright
don't flag the video so if you're not up
for the challenge
eh then click the [ __ ] away and don't
flag the video man I should be a rapper
that was pretty good
videos cuz I'm better than you I'm a
virgin tears on my fingers while I'm
learning lots of my basement get to the
surface never show my face keyboard is
my fortress key to the Internet you
better get reporting you push the base
image is visiting [ __ ] if this is
offensive you don't have to listen to
not the computer do something productive
you cancerous people it covers and
nothing you hide them behind this
security suite human beings have
breathing maturity [ __ ] your opinion is
that [ __ ] don't mean nothin to me just
fix it this black you move on with your
life oh here we are back at it again
holy [ __ ] oh my god I am NOT bearable I
hate this up should be knock yeah hello
the [ __ ] sticks
hey they got corn and everything I'm low
they miss the man man you look good man
oh Jesus Christ get the [ __ ] out of me
why is their tricycle here oh god it's
getting dark man it's getting well dark
man oh [ __ ]
you know shits about to go down when the
drum starts hitting it oh god this is
[ __ ] freaky man
what was that
all right but this is pretty good
subpart what a nice town oh my god [ __ ]
indeed oh that's cool man this is so
[ __ ] cool whoa what the [ __ ]
hey no I hear you Ethan Bradberry [ __ ]
are you doing you [ __ ] [ __ ]
well you gotta be so loud man I ain't
scared
Oh Jeff not a big dot Oh corn I love
corn so much time over oh that guy
I am so [ __ ] oh my god I'm fine fine
I'm fine I'm fine
well where am I excuse me
I broke when I'm excited miter doesn't
appreciate it I know but whoa it's licky
tongue again that [ __ ] Pokemon scat
mate see a [ __ ] is a oh okay no that's
great that's funny cuz I was actually
heading this way towards the exit
yes oh come on
all right come out puts out a shudder
ran out of batteries what was that
what the [ __ ] is out there Oh God Jesus
[Music]
Christ get the [ __ ] outta my new company
be three big bouncy boobies all right
who's got the biggest titties
flat-chest know it get the [ __ ] up get
the [ __ ] out Zoe Kiana you got that ass
but get that what [ __ ] do you take
before we're called a big teddy
Nicky you look like you're from tumblr I
despise you I hate your guts but
business is business and you're hired
Nikki Bella you're in okay we got Lyle
on e she's Asian
flat-chest honey why do you show up get
up
all right so Zoe we had this talk before
it's time to hire another one okay we
got Lillian
she's teen tattoos [ __ ] up [ __ ] off
Lillian why is it so hard
are we hiring her you better get some
implants all right what's her cup size B
finally from Candice you're in [ __ ]
sake you're all useless one dollar per
hour Kiana you're in Tiffany one dollar
an hour
Tiffany you're in you're in now buy me
shoes oh my god Zoe how many times are
you trying how many [ __ ] times I
gotta tell you so II get the [ __ ] out
and stop wasting my time you got zero
potential zero hey Tiffany wear this
butt plug while you go shopping
butt plug friend Zoe you want him
working this business so hard
here take this butt plug why me see
cigarettes
[ __ ] up I'm gonna have to hire my last
car Marlena
but she said naturally but ain't nothing
natural about that girl oh my god that
money
finally finally I'm rollin the pimp
business my mom would be so proud of me
right now
the way I handle women with such dignity
and respect would approve of this video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you bros voted if I was an anime
character what would I be an anime
schoolgirl
you hear that Easley I'm an enemy
schoolgirl
thanks to you bros voting on Twitter
thank you so much there's so many cool
animes but anyway school girl just what
I wanted
thank you appreciate it so thanks to
crunchyroll we bring in that to life but
that's what this video is going to be
but first for those of you who don't
know about crunchyroll
it's a streaming service of anime and
drama it's a service that I personally
use as well so I'm really happy to have
them as sponsor and making this pretty
pie enemy a real thing
huge thanks to them I'm a fan of anime
myself what can I say I enjoy a good
berserk I sound like a mom trying to say
like yeah I watch anime I enjoy a good
GTO really great shows they're all
available on crunchyroll and I would
love to hear your brother's opinion on
them so check them out they have over
25,000 anime episodes I'm sure you'll
find something that you'll enjoy but not
just that you're supporting the Japanese
anime industry by supporting crunchable
because every season they're bringing in
the freshest anime straight from Japan
so basically if you check out the link
in the description crunchyroll.com slash
boots you got a 30-day free trial to
check it out and see if you like it you
basically can watch as much anime you
want for 30 days with no ads 1080p baby
and the newest episodes air one after
they are up in Japan with professional
subtitles I think that's pretty cool
I really enjoy it so maybe you will as
well and thanks again for crunchyroll
for making this happen now let's roll
the clip
[Music]
hey what you doing not much just hanging
[Music]
hey what are you guys talking about
oh hi just chatting about the big game
tonight why do you get what we're
talking about I was just trying to talk
- we all know you're obsessed with him
everyone sees you taking photos of him
everywhere no I don't why don't you just
leave him alone for once he'll never be
yours get over it
[Music]
alright girls
take it easy now
[Music]
[Music]
he's not yours you'll never come even
close to what I feel for him they'll
miss you little rats
[Music]
this is all your fault yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
any last words little freak suck on my
laser [ __ ] she was right I'll never
have him but if I can't have him I must
be
[Music]
it's this game
sup bro you know what's up brother it's
been eight days and you still haven't
recalibrated your puzzles what are you
even doing hey take it easy I gotten a
ton of work done today
ask la ton ah I only attended my
possible ask for your whack put your
little more backbone into it human I'll
scare your soul out of your body
oh god it's one of those meanings damn
boy you [ __ ] hard call me names now I
hate making promises but that promise I
made to her you know what would ever
happen if she hadn't said anything buddy
you'd be dead hey latinum Paco I'm just
joking me besides haven't I done a great
job protecting you I mean look at
yourself you haven't died a single time
hey what's that look supposed to me
am I wrong
[Music]
so it's the fun you you bring your hands
up begin to concentrate coalescing the
arcane energy into the strange dull glow
of green in your hands as the swirl
continues to spiral you shoot your hands
forward releasing this burst of
corrosive energy towards the fetus it's
been a while since you've used this
explosive power in this town in earnest
you weren't paying attention to your
target the arrow arcs to the side
missing your target instead of striking
kalim in the back of the shoulders and
even trying to put him out of his misery
you manage to pierce him with the rapier
because he's not moving but you don't
reach any vital organs so now you're
just adding more pain to his slowly
sizzling misery you have no idea what
this building is as you shout that out
let's define you turn around and look up
and immediately see a sign hanging over
the door that says butcher oh how do you
not notice that Cinderella what knows
what look at the sign right there what
signs if this butcher no it doesn't door
clicks and opens up into a dark interior
you have that light spell still I
already used it can I can't be bothered
to use light spell you can do an
infinite number of times yeah I know
okay how's your light spell in rainbow
color very beautiful array of rainbow
colors streaks across the room you can
now see indeed this is a butcher shop
there is a large a fabulous butcher shop
dead unicorns everywhere okay where's
the board the blood goin this is the
part where I say let's just go back okay
can I catch a rainbow spell to make this
situation a little nicer you can you
passed your right spell an array of
beautiful colors lighting up the tunnel
as you guys not so quietly turned the
corner with this vibrant bright rainbow
lie
expelling from the front of Stefan's
quarter staff the large figure pulls its
hood back and you can see what looks
like a snarling ogre face standing about
12 to 13 feet tall its head is bulbous
and mutated like some sort of pulsating
creature has taken root on the right
side of its face its eyes beeline
unnatural intelligence for its kind who
interrupts our sacred gifting ceremony I
will know your names in intent so we
might whisper them to the silence
screamer and crush your memory on this
world and with that we will leave this
game on a cliffhanger
[Music]
[Laughter]
can we lose Killeen yes okay come here
daddy if you look down your face like
goes into your chest and your knees are
already in your chest
oh there's a there's a strange object
here which is oh very inappropriate
you put down the strange rubber object
can I pick it up
daddy wait daddy anyways
rematch hey I found bleach no no daddy
one don't drink the bleach I don't know
how I did it
you inside it okay there's an electrical
cabinet there I got a pretty no Timmy no
no your trash put me in the trash oh I
won't go into twice hey you want going
to trash going I want to go to twice
you're going go in Detroit yeah you go
trash this game is clearly flawless ten
out of ten 10/10 IGN best idea around 10
IMDB Oscar Rotten Tomatoes bonus game
for this game can I interest you in a
bucket perhaps what's that sound
thanks fuzzy go realism completed hello
[Music]
listen y'all God is sexually [ __ ]
creepy ha that your [ __ ] oh my god oh
[Music]
god I'm actually terrified what the [ __ ]
Jennifer what are you doing here daddy
what do you shut that yes turn barrels
[ __ ] leave me alone
[Music]
it's just a prank bro it's just a prank
the cameras right there bro the cameras
right there that's just a prank bro it's
just a prank
thanks bro I guess you don't like pranks
I stole your car just a prank bro I
[ __ ] your wife just a prank bro I gave
you just a prank bro it ruined your life
bro can't you people understand
[Music]
it's just a prank bro
just a break the camera is right there
the cameras right there Frank
don't you
oh I guess you don't like pranks
I've got your fire just a prank bro burn
down your house bro I need your children
to pray that wasn't a prank though can't
you people understand that it's just got
me as [ __ ] funny that's why it's okay
prank
just to break the camera
the cameras right Frank on fire
[Music]
it's just a prank bro it's just a prank
the camera is right there brother
cameras right there that's just a prank
bro it's just a prank
don't you like pranks bro I guess you
don't like brains in the beginning there
was nothing
well actually there was a lot of stuff
but it was boring and then there was the
broken podcast on one side is sexy Swede
known as PewDiePie
on the other the American Gear the
cinnamon toast can and the podcast was
so good it brought light into this dark
and toxic world what this that's a bit
intense don't you think anyway it
welcomes special guests like markiplier
jacksepticeye crime and international
Rockstar President Obama that last one
is a lie there were cables challenges
and conversations so legendary that the
animals still sing of their glory
whatever now we're open podcasters
making history once again coming to
sling TV so get ready to experience the
pro fist like you've never experienced
before and you better watch because if
you don't then the rope
we'll win that last one is also a lie
maybe the broken podcast available now
on sling TV ah yes ah yes say my Santa
Claus I think I'm Santa Claus so what
would Santa Claus do in a situation like
this I would steal all their [ __ ] boom
that's my bicycle this is my TV santa
needs gifts too
what else do we need Christmas pudding
all year that's my Christmas pudding
no no what else Oh money twenty money
money money money money money money so
much money oh my god
there's a painting there this ugly-ass
painting yes I mean it's probably worth
a fortune dude
okay oh god they're coming oh god
they're coming I've got a bit of height
I better hide in the closet thank God oh
my god Tom Cruise Tom Cruise stop stop
Tom Cruise Tom Cruise is bidding the
[ __ ] out of me aah run run run run run
run Brad I'm sorry who would beat up
Santa whoo-hoo I'm an everyday thief
thief no I'm Sam I'm Santa was reverse
gifting I was gift traversing have you
never heard of that
you take [ __ ] from people it's great
hey Tom it's me I got all your [ __ ]
Tommy tone doesn't know what to do I got
all your [ __ ] what you gonna do about it
[ __ ] in your face oh my god
that was amazing
you
[Music]
gonzalo hey it's been too long man hello
how are you I sell melons
would you like to bike guess not
come on man let me aim guns Allah
whatever it's bit - yeah yeah yeah yeah
where's the wine oh no here we are
that shrieky boys Gonzalo alright guys
this has been great by the way you look
fabulous
oh why did you say so girl hey I know
I'm fabulous I can't hear you over how
fab I am anyway I can't I like your ball
I like your balls
I like your balls to race
alright I'm gonna go to the kitchen
Gonzalo are you trying to leave the room
again
milk well just come back to the living
room quit screwing around you guys are
mean okay no really don't come again
solo come on we really just want you to
come back in here [ __ ] yo you know what
no Gonzalo
that's it ah you need to he went through
the wall here superpowers we invited you
over but this is just Nanami goat you
demon you g---men hunter [ __ ] you [ __ ]
off piece piece of [ __ ] god damn it I
knew I should just take the wine and
left so long since we've seen you
how are you doing I'm pretty good thank
you
Ginevra damnit i missed my hi hi how are
you I am so happy to see you after so
long that's funny I said the same thing
hilarious
[Music]
hey how's it going bros my name is dont
be a solid be the best god damn broccoli
you could ever be
[Music]
you can make fun of me you can make fun
of my hair but if you make fun of my
hair I'll [ __ ] stab a [ __ ] no diving
you can't tell me what to do well [ __ ]
spank my butt you have permission to
steal a bit bába sáí bába sáí bába ah
it's itchy yeah smack that [ __ ] nothing
in life will ever be the same after this
you're missing your mitt you're miss OH
let it go let it go alright first that
will be
[Music]
another survival zombie multiplayer game
on Steam early access with
microtransactions hey you know what I'm
sorry it might actually be good I don't
want to be the guy who just judged [ __ ]
I want to be respectful and I want to
give this game the best chance it could
possibly deserve let's do this are you
[ __ ] wait never play these [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna get my
15 pounds of fun it's the last thing
I'll ever do oh it's it what they told
me I couldn't build the medieval
McDonald's they were proud I never I
never seen art in such a profound way
until I played Viking McDonald's
simulator 2015 are these the meat of
Jesus man I know how to flip the mugs
man Jesus look at night
we're gonna make a sale for little
burger bad habit out don't just make
burgers we have to make enough okay fine
what did use you all these burgers are
burnt they look like hockey pucks
god damn rats I'll get you one day I'll
get you I'm gonna [ __ ] murder you oh
hey there sorry that's don't worry
that's just our pets our intern is
mentally challenged now all our
ingredients are [ __ ] dirty are
[ __ ] dirty man some say if the meat
looks like a hockey puck you shouldn't
need it I say Yolo
it's like an Oreo that's great nice so
this is my specialty I call it cancer in
a burger
I got a problem with my burger what is
this [ __ ] we thought I got damn it
who thought that was a good idea I'll go
advertise good be naked sex say it cells
what is intern doing in turn three I
have a new bucks to fight the other box
[Music]
what are they leaving what's wrong with
[Music]
this game is like Skyrim hey how's it
going bros my name is - my favorite game
of all time
June Dara is simulator whoa I'm in here
now I can what you see why I say it's my
favorite game because I can change my
underwear I'm going for the striped
blends cos the stripes shows up the
curls dokdo girls but
let's go to school so what our plan for
this episode is to make someone fall off
this roof you have amazing side boobs
make a Chan so does the other girl a
real laughing and having fun bra having
fun right so much fun
dry so anyway about that tampon how do I
get it out all right so here a family
you can eavesdrop on people if they
don't see you and I obviously have
amazing Sugoi dis or Chan panties I mean
sneaking skills stored on and make a
child oh my god well it's nothing if you
don't talk about it that's fine ever
since my mom died my dad's been drinking
a lot sometimes when he's drunk he comes
into my room and
[Music]
what's this I can almost see me a chance
panties this is gonna pay for walking
near Sam pies presents 4 p.m. where the
[ __ ] is she oh that son of a [ __ ] where
is she there's yes
no one can see me I am there danger
alright justice alright brother second
I'm saying that if you're so there this
game is so awesome I can't wait to play
more wants to get updated grocery you
enjoyed this video now's a great time to
leave a like and I'll see you in the
next one it's always stay also gross
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey buddy Hey look at me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
No
[Music]
[Music]
I live in uncertainty every day every
time I look at myself in the clear cool
waters of Africa I expect to see a
beautiful giraffe staring back at me but
all I see is a [ __ ] lover I was lost
without hope in this desolate world why
was Mother Earth so cruel as to not
grant me with the noscopes I so
desperately deserved and also for the
body of a giraffe hello my name is
Falcon Lord X X X X X hello hello my
name is Falcon Lord X X X capital X X X
X I am a trans species human to giraffe
the wide fields of Africa is where I
belong but yet why do I feel so lost I
think of the Falcon lovers of the world
and how they have taken me so far
but even I would only have 3 subs
instead with 3000 if it weren't for him
pity the way he yells into his
microphone as he plays games the way his
golden hair falls like waves over his
sky-blue eyes it makes me want to cry
Pierce is my senpai and I the co I who
he will never notice I sigh in the
wandering hole listening to the far-off
sounds of elephants and gazelles roaming
the sun-soaked blades the sounds of
Africa are so peaceful contradicting my
thunderstorm of feelings why one Pierce
ever noticed me yes he has made videos
acknowledging my existence but I was
nothing more than a laughingstock to him
a joke a falcon
sir who would want anything to do with
me suddenly a loud cry Pierce's my
eardrums who wants to do this I think
isn't this supposed to be you
oh I think it'd be funny if you try to
be me let's have a beauty off let's do
this alright okay you go first
are you working for the Pharaohs alright
this is my money are you working for the
barrels all looks like you're good
Martin yeah buddy I blink familiar voice
the way the volume of the tone almost
gave me a freaking heart attack could it
be no I think shaking my head it's
definitely not this better increase the
noscopes I guess it is pity pay
immediately I stand and spin around
running towards the sand what I see
shucks me he was surrounded by lions
trying to fight them off with his laptop
you're fighting a lion damn it here's
cried after smacking one of the Lions
upside the head and seeing it was
unharmed
pity pie I cry I must save him price to
bring it to action brushing over and
making my breast raft call just half of
the Lions ears start bleeding and they
run away living Pierce in the grand I
rush to pierce and kneel before him hey
Perry pack oh yeah
a yellow beauty bye oh yeah
are you hurt Peter pie groans okay Lord
kids ask ya
it saved me I just care elated type hits
I cried sparkly enemy tears falling from
my face I love you your smiles I love
you
suddenly we embrace and my one dream has
come true
[Music]
after turning into a duck cry 1 over 2
pewds instead it's okay come I'll take
you to my dear home dramatic I liked it
he cared for words did little use into
his arms and started walking views
looked at cry with big eyes you know we
have known it for a long time now we
started to suspect something when you
try to hook up with a swine you started
blushing I was just so embarrassed
he's squat they walked home together in
Christ said come on make dinner he
suddenly got an evil looking face but
Pitt's did not care he was so in love
with the strong white man cry hesitated
and went into the kitchen he did not say
anything when Puetz walked in cried
turns around slowly he was creepy and
scary now let's eat he said as he waved
with a knife and a fork
Pete's backed off cry what are you doing
I suddenly wanted to have duck for
dinner pute started to walk a little bit
fast backwards in cry followed and
before he knew it period started running
why are you chasing me try I thought you
loved me
screamed way moving my way you have to
yell I loved it I loved our key screams
loud is that good well it's not like
you're narrating would you say that's a
perfect jude's went to the bathroom but
there were no places sure on it or cry
what what why was there an oar there
puce went to the bathroom but there were
no places to run or and then Christ
smashed into the baby idea which is if
like Christ machine to the doors I
impacted you as he'll like mid-sentence
that's so intense Wow intense person
there again she went into the bathroom
but there were no places to run or I
smashed in the door I like duck salty he
was insane pewds had place to go the
toilet he jumped up on the toilet seat
pulled the lever and flushed himself
down he tried to hold his breath but he
got choked by the water anyway Oh No but
suddenly he felt ere he could breathe he
took a deep breath I went a little
overboard there where I am I you're the
source stupid an Italian voice that kind
of sounds Italian said could it be the
other true love of his Stefan how you
tried to look after a little gold Tim
statue in the dark but couldn't see
anything
also parity long time no see
[Music]
many years ago in a kingdom chord bro
lot there lived a brave knight by the
name of sir PewDiePie he was king at cos
and Queen Maya's most valuable Knight
from the square table one day King ad
can summon sir pewdiepie to his chamber
to ask for a favor sir parity pie both I
and Queen Maya believe that you are the
only person we can trust with this
mission you must find the sword named
Stephano and use it to slay the dragon
cryotic King ed car instructed this was
a hurdle staying the dragon cry a tick
only a madman would do such a thing
at first sir pewdiepie refused
vigorously but then king ed car said
something that sparked his interest if
you successfully slayed the dragon and
saved the princes locked in the tower
you will be able to marry her how could
he resist such an offer everyone knew
the princess looked in the tower was the
most beautiful princess in all of the
land skin like ivory eyes the color of
chocolate and a lovely deep voice I will
find the sword slay the dragon and save
the princess before sundown tomorrow sir
pewdiepie proclaimed throwing his fist
in the air as if the battle had already
been won I am glad to hear it the king
said with a smile but please allow me to
send you with a few others for backup
and this backup happened to be Marcia a
beautiful and talented Alchemist who
knew her way with magic and the would
help him oh wait what it makes you sound
like she knows her way with magic and me
like do you see how I just read that
that threw me off okay
this backup happened to be Marcia a
beautiful and talented Alchemist who
knew her way with magic and the wood elf
Martin the trek to find the sword was
long
perilous many trials and tribulations
stood in their way the pit of duels the
tomb of malice and even the field of
fabulous but nothing stood in the way of
sir beauty pie and his truth he reached
the large rock that held the mighty
sword Stephano and grasped its handle
victoriously i sir pewdiepie of bro
alert proclaimed this sword is mine
he yelled as he pulled at the sword and
pulled at the sword and pulled the sword
again no matter how many times he tried
the sword would not budge marzia walked
up to the weapon and swiftly pulled it
out with one tug before handing it to
the night oh wait is this your only life
do I need to sound like very like really
sound really tipper ya hell man what a
jovial sight to see sir pewdiepie are
you not the strongest in the land your
way to get at that is that ok it was fun
we shall see who's strong would I slay
the dragon he proclaimed they traveled
another few weeks before reaching the
castle where the princess lived they
snuck through the gates and met with a
300 foot horror that was the cry attic
dragon sir just hanging out you know all
right here we go they raised their
weapons and stared into the white face
of the dragon people charging at full
speed Christ's mouth because he knew all
too well of the break Knights body I'm
glad you came I love Swedish meatballs
for dinner dad cried mode yet
[Music]
what is what what is this you [ __ ]
call this grass that's the worst grass
I've seen in my life
are you [ __ ] kidding me what are you
doing are you would it stop twitching
you've got damn cow all right so we have
some demon cows in a grass simulator
game great just what I had hope stop oh
god this is terrifying
all right you know what I'm going in no
more grass for me oh god the grass is
everywhere alrights everywhere make the
gret a gun really like hey go shoot the
grass or take this scratch you'll never
get me alive infinite demo slow-mo
shooting that grass 360 360 noscope
alright the grass is still alive I don't
know what to do do I shoot the cows I'm
sorry demon cow you fatty Oh can't kill
them can kill the devil huh
[Music]
Hagrid smirked and looked up from the
buffet of firm tight flesh that lays
spread edge before him to tilt his head
questioningly what the [ __ ]
Dumbledore grinned he has been very good
he said thoughtfully tracing the crease
of harry's hurt arse with a fingertip I
think he deserves both dark eyes Harry
babbles something incoherent with the
frantic movement of his for a long
moment the older men lost himself in
familiar tastes our God then the sound
of an indignant and neglected Harry
broke you through their less driven snog
being frenzy well someone just Haggard
and Dumbledore chuckled as Dumbledore
picked up as one releasing Harry's bonds
before he cast lubrication spells Harry
gasped then he yelps when he felt rough
hands all him to his knees and the blunt
tip of nudging the entrance to his body
Agra shudder to his own release and
after Harry sucked him down to the base
and swallowed heard around his ha
everybody he whimpered as Harry's hand
slid between his legs here one key he
hasted thee and ya
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie that was weird
mr. Crabb that's dr. crab excuse me very
much
hi talks oh look there's so many of them
you're so kawaii
I have a doctorate I don't deserve this
I can said them I just murdered your
entire family how does that make you
feel
who's the doctor now wouldn't you save
them if you're such a good doctor then
why is your family dead all right that
was pretty dark and horrible
[Applause]
I'm making a lefty
[Music]
let's chop down this palm tree it looks
like it's correcting
[Music]
this one goes out to all of y'all who's
struggling to get high views on YouTube
I'm about to tell you the secret that no
one knows about to accept me and cuz I
just figured it out
listen carefully boys and girls hey yo
it's the number one [ __ ] oh never back
the seat down relax
here have a snack have a mound or 6-pack
I'm sorry for my grammar swag but we're
getting up to track the song is about
Iraq no I'm not talking about the nation
I'm here to tell you all about the great
simulation if she were official videos
from what YouTube used that he might be
seduced they might come to use we all
been there we all has struggled you try
to pay for subs
they just sonata scrubs here's how to do
class but they just gives you some crabs
you're trying to false flag and your
massive pause tags what's the secret to
you preview so must be a trick are they
part of Illuminati no its way that can
be do they work really hard
do they commit no you got it all wrong
because your luncheonette it senator
and a thumbnail
get some money after
get some boobs in a thumbnail [ __ ] no I
can't do that this should very nice my
mom says you better think about it twice
folks in a thumbnail
put some moves in it
okay I'm sorry sorry the trick is simple
I learned from the best
the secret lies within a nice opponent's
chest you may want to consider having
implants you may wanna consider having
em
okay now don't get me wrong I'm not
being sexist I should only say that poop
they don't matter what your sex is
showing you a picture of your dick ain't
nobody's gonna click on that [ __ ] come
on man arrow that's close you should
consider having implants you should
consider having implants everybody you
should consider having implants you
should consider having implants another
time is to commit are you gonna be a
[ __ ] or you gonna make people click on
that jig legit just think of all the
reasons I know you want it just get it
and that it and make us try yours get
busy wed a person a thumbnail [ __ ] with
some boobs and a thumbnail
[ __ ] but what about my integrity just
kidding as long as I can put a bunch of
boobie boobs and a thumb now [ __ ] with
the burbs and
[ __ ] true [ __ ] settle now
everybody you shoulda somehow
you should be sitting
but but I'm a boy I don't wanna dance
selling em again but the truth is
setting have a campaign
[Music]
Erbs boobs thank you that's right I
killed Robocop
how you ask lactation when I was
tripping on acid white people turn into
black people what don't you want to find
in your kung pao chicken michael
jackson's final moment we thought about
Justin Bieber for my next trick I will
pull a saxophone solo out of an erectile
dysfunction erectile dysfunction you can
get
instead of cold father Christmas now
gives the bad children funny
what did the US air drop drop to this
children of Afghanistan this is gonna be
bad a cooler full of organs then I tell
ya we got Natalie Portman finally what
are they doing to Natalie Portman
[Music]
on the first day of Christmas and gare
said to me the recipe for madam better
meat on the second day of Christmas
Edgar sent to me to leave your batteries
and the recipe for madam better mean on
the third day of Christmas
Edgar sent to me three litres of acetone
two lithium batteries and the recipe for
methamphetamine on the fourth day of
Christmas Edgar sent to me four cans of
hydrochloric acid three litres of
acetone two lithium batteries and the
recipe for man
better mean on the fifth day of
Christmas and you're sent to me five top
top fingers for cats hydrochloric acid
three litres of acetone to lithium
batteries and the recipe for
methamphetamine on the sixth day of
Christmas and you're sent to me six
chicken buckets five chopped up fingers
for cancer fighter chloric acid three
leaves of acetone to leave your
batteries and the recipe for madam
better mean on the seventh day of
Christmas and you're said to me seven
Brennan cache six chicken buckets five
chopped off fingers
for cancer fighter Cory Cass said three
liters of acetone to lithium batteries
and the recipe for methamphetamine
on the eighth day of Christmas Edgar
sent to me eight pics of my mom seven
grand in cash six chicken buckets five
chopped off fingers for chemspider
chloric acid three layers of acetone -
lithium batteries and the recipe for
madam better mean on the ninth day of
Christmas and you're sent to me nine
Mexicans and coats eight pics of my mom
seven grand in cash six chicken buckets
five top topping Ertz four cans of
hydrochloric acid three layers of
acetone two lithium batteries and the
recipe for madam better mean on the
tenth day of Christmas Edgar sent to me
ten dead prostitutes nine Mexicans and
coats eight pics of my mom seven
branding cash six chicken buckets five
chopped off fingers four cats of
hydrochloric acid three layers of
acetone two lithium batteries and the
recipe for methamphetamine on the
eleventh day of Christmas and you're
sent to me eleven cops shooting ten dead
prostitutes nine mix against and codes
eight picks my mom seven grand in cash
six chicken buckets
I've chopped up fingers for cats vitae
car gas save three layers of acetone to
lithium batteries and the recipe for
methamphetamine on the twelfth day of
Christmas Edgar sent to me he made me
his [ __ ] and now he calls me Jessie
[Music]
how's it going bros beautifu hope you
bros enjoyed that christmas special it
was made by cypher den she did an
amazing job so go check out our channel
i'll leave a link here go subscribe and
tell her I sent you
gross have a great Christmas if you
don't celebrate Christmas have a happy
holidays or happy whatever you'll be
doing thank you so much for this amazing
year and I want to thank you all for for
being there here's a brofist for many
more breasts stay awesome this ever
happen to you are you peeing on me yeah
well what are you gonna do buddy
nothing he's right luckily I find this
tutorial on how to draw a horse
hopefully that'll help alright for the
final step I got damage I am a
vegetarian but I want to eat your face
hello 911 I like to report a vegetarian
yes yes he is trying to eat my face oh
wait I was supposed to get one of the
drinks at heart god damn it which one
that I put the drugs in I got there but
I forgot I better drink both but I need
to know if you're the chosen one that I
asked its holy how can we if I have 26
million subscribers while there's only 7
to 80 million people on earth fake a
[ __ ] I I don't know how to explain that
to you you might just die from a brain
fart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
every are running in a horror game again
when are they gonna start putting
checkpoints in these games find a note
they're supposed to be a note yeah
you think being the most subscribed
[ __ ] and YouTube would help all right
there's the pooper let's go to the
pooper dancer guy - line
thank god there's still hope Russ
there's still hope for our cake let it
go let it go man yeah oh my god I got a
high fly myself a catch I'm to retire
I'm too stupid I can't I can't believe I
saw Kim Kardashian good for you good for
you yes I came today yeah good for you
good for you good for you get you I get
for you kids for you good for you good
for you
all right you know what we're gonna have
to expand here I think it's about time
that we kill somebody
yes oh my god this is gonna be awesome
no why did I do that no lady what are
you doing here
[Music]
Oh God two is missing now where where
oh hey Oh sir how are you doing going
out for a midnight snack
well this is the restroom you [ __ ] it's
a [ __ ] go to the right restaurant
idiot you have beautiful eyes also but
seriously no midnight selfies please oh
god where is she Oh for the love of
dicks are they moving they're not moving
so far what is missing 1s missing where
and hey-hey chap Oh God where did he go
jaw bloody feet dance ballet wait [ __ ]
you [ __ ] off whoa well what the [ __ ] is
that what the [ __ ] are you is it more
than no oh god no oh god no oh God oh
that is some creepy [ __ ] man you cannot
come in and eat here no you can't you
[ __ ] go home you're drunk stop go home
oh oh oh that's great
I want to go home now I'm pretty sure
that whatever they paying me here is not
worth it let's get cocky you sounded
great why thank you Sam you should be a
dinghy
you should join expected we're singing
can't it Billy
no I'm just kidding you're awful Wow
what the [ __ ] is wrong with me this
should just be called nightmare
generator ow ah ah for the love of God
this game I didn't ask for this someone
do something got ya back I [ __ ] hate
you P de pie you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
with gay fight hair you can make fun of
me you can make fun of my hair but if
you make fun of my hair I'll [ __ ]
stab a [ __ ] free pie you suck and you
swallow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it's a wonderful morning the sun is
shining the birds are tweeting their
birds get off my time oh you did a
little [ __ ] to work there for a
second that's that's beautiful
I'm scared hello Leslie protect me
[ __ ] you [ __ ] I never liked you anyway
I'm Eddie here do you wanna die bro do
you want it that's CDs as a necklace
that's adorable
where did you get it
Tiffany's rich it never [ __ ] learn
let's build some more refugees expense
well I just mush mushrooms oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm up here now
what am I doing here crying I don't know
what are you doing up there what have
you done bro go through there okay all
right fine okay okay you shoot that
portal there I'm gonna go through there
no no no I got a platform I got a plan
already done yeah I got the plan ready
yes so we gonna do this it'll make less
than I make no you shoot Paula listen to
me your father
listen to me no no [ __ ] Paul there see
you don't even know what you're talking
about
no she's not know that don't you know me
no no sure boo God you should have all
that you should run that you should you
choose you you should you should you
already shot used to you should you
should I will cry cry cry cry cry do you
remember what September it did
oh there's a thing over here and see
that you see this I do actually
[Music]
[Music]
wait before I do anything you see how it
says Bob there good good because I
getting so many [ __ ] messages being
you copy blah blah blah because you call
him Bob it's okay
I'm gonna let this one slide because you
are beautiful isn't that right Bob
what there's the [ __ ] Chama okay you
might feel a little headache Bob but
that's normal
tomahawk chop it was going so well
oh no way there's a brain in there oh
man I we have to cut it off oh [ __ ] why
is it not working I don't got it ahh
better hurry up give me the drill
professional I can't work with this yes
Bob you look so good today what what
you're gonna be so [ __ ] smart after
this we [ __ ] get it yeah look spied
yeah I think I put it on right I don't
know I'm not sure I hope you bros enjoy
to leave a man that your dad is [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
crime zooming in on your Beth I hope you
don't mind I have mine none
I like the shakiness of your move thank
you I've worked hard on this what is
that it might be can we have no we
should not know humping the wildlife I'm
sorry okay actually there might be a dog
well it's a bit thighs the cow cry it's
a fat dog no it's a cow no no let's it's
approaching me hey cow hi okay well we
gotta tame the beast now we can ride
into victim oh that would be so awesome
can you punch it or something series
will learn in its place Oh like yes I
can see your face up close yeah but I
don't know what to say beautiful
yes yeah all right let's run with our
flashes we gotta go the tags on these
with flashlights yeah that's our job
I'm ready for this we gotta inspect the
whole fact that there's a freaking
zombie apocalypse you're - exactly are
you drunk
going there but screw that going that
crap I'm going this way
nice
okay look at this guy stand on that
button standing on this button nice then
man thanks oh I got it
you fly here you land there and then
launch there I got it before you got it
don't worry about it cry okay no problem
how do I get back the portals up and you
die alright that's nice fighting with
your side man I love you know you say
like don't do it whatever you do man
it's worth living
kill yourself hey I'm fine Bob
don't worry I'm up by myself I can't do
it I cannot do it nah oh god damn it
I'll sign your [ __ ] face is that you
back on Ken man you look it's gonna my
boobs pumped up you know yeah it looks
so conceited I'm just a pleased to be
here beauty
what are you here are you going to spend
Valentine's Day with Ken cry noticed the
flowers and pointed at them are those
freaking beautiful Oh No we thought for
you cry was astonished beauty what are
you trying to say I'm trying to say that
I I really liked you for a while now and
the king I may even have more feelings
than like and won't he be mad
I mean sad
I think I love you you vanished
[Laughter]
Beauty I'm flattered I really am but I
have asked about I left Ken
dude you're down at the floorboard
straddling his thongs why would you
leave him you two were so happy together
well it seemed like pee they looked up
at cry staring into his eyes for you I
mean you have to be waiting friends I'm
sorry
oh and cry what is it
do they lean forward clothes are
enclosed in - cries ear cry will you be
my Valentine go into this building
there's the best weapon in the game in
this building right here your trick how
dare you I trusted you do something
about it okay don't hit me over trust
I'm gonna try to get you out oh oh
best weapon in the game huh best weapon
in the game I see how it is
come here come here and free me come in
and free me Kylie cool be cool be cool
I'm cool I'm cool all right I can't do
anything I think you're stuck for life
okay you attention server I know you
should kill the in the town so if you
look on your map okay he's out
[Music]
that's [ __ ] get hope you bros enjoyed
this video thank you so much 2k
automation for making it you can go
ahead and check out his channel here and
subscribe and for more information go
ahead and click here that's all
stay awesome breasts god damn this game
crap this is like you need to be a
Eileen Stein or Tesla hey wait your eyes
open yeah we can sit here all along
you're looking at that and not tell them
good story fine let's go you're the
wrong part of Kyle's boy I'm fine don't
worry about it don't worry about it
don't worry right so much fun play with
you
[Music]
don't worry about it
[Music]
work it work it work it quick how's the
OMS - we're gonna do the kidney
transplant yes
I'll read your bra's comments and I
think we're ready for this [ __ ] aren't
we Bob you're in my domain now [ __ ]
so a lot of others said that you don't
want me as your surgeon don't make me
slap you again don't make me slap you I
don't really care what do you mean by
that why isn't it not working Bob why is
it not that the working I'm such a
professional Hey eat it eat it
see if I care you dick now I don't bite
me light saber oh [ __ ] sorry about that
Bobby burn his nipples a little bit nice
and easy there we go oh shut sorry about
that Bobby buh-bye little laser go not
on me but calm down off with the lights
are off with the laser drill did I tell
you to start down thing no I did [ __ ]
not let's grab this whole thing oh I
love your new scarf Bob Oh or your
fabulous love it I was going so well
that's right
[Music]
that's my slapping sound effect don't
even worry about holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] I don't want to be a
doctor anymore nope don't you doubt fine
Mac oh that's right I'm the boss of you
[ __ ] oh okay okay okay [ __ ] okay don't
you die bleed on me Bob I will [ __ ]
kill you if you die
oh it's in [ __ ] perfect match that
will make us a perfect Matt we're like
Oh
high-five that was [ __ ] awesome
sergeant complete looks fine to me I'm
sure Liv alright next opera's brain
transplant that'll be great
Miranda you dirty [ __ ] stop calling me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
how you do it Bob how you doing it's all
gonna be good
you're in safe hands dr. Pitts is in in
in the house yeah hi Bob you may feel a
slight pain in your chest area don't
worry it's normal and if your balls
tickled that's normal two and three one
two three that's how we don't want any
pot on [ __ ] get out what the [ __ ] are
you the [ __ ] are you that is liver ah
are they by cuddling let's not kill
high-five
no you [ __ ] don't make me slap you
I do believe this is how you hold the
scissor that's how they teach you in
school isn't it I Bob just gotta aah
okay there come on baby aah all right
let's get the stomach out hey yo yo need
that [ __ ] yeah disgusting isn't it Bob
that is come on baby don't you dare die
on me now Bob Yolo mode get my [ __ ] in
there
it said that's n Ed's [ __ ] in an
Italian what do you want from me surgery
fell and it's going so well
[Music]
ah
stop calling me Miranda I don't want to
date you desperate [ __ ] are you ready
for the insertion baby oh that's right
yeah nah what the [ __ ]
don't you dare resist my insurgent what
I finger you
[Music]